um
[Music]
words on the
program reading the program this morning
i thought
what type is going to be put there
sorry
i was going to keep this short but maybe
maybe maybe not
all right
yeah so um as you all know core
ingredients to
the perception of privacy is exhibiting
presumably our average space nature
which are hard for classical uh
polynomial time algorithms but which you
have efficient quantum algorithms so
we're really excited
to have lumash tell us about recent work
on putting this
okay so uh
so
my my charge was exactly to say um try
to say what are the open questions you
know what to build up towards the
main questions that um
you know that that remain
open uh
in terms of um
putting quantum supremacy on a rigorous
city
so let me let me try to uh
uh and and you know i i want to uh
uh so i want to get to the to the
questions that are that are really
um and the goal of this and hopefully uh
you know some that you can you can
tackle without really uh doing knowing
too much
okay so um
um
so here were the the here's the backdrop
um a couple of years ago google uh
announced uh
announced their quantum supremacy
experiment based on
52-qubit quantum circuits uh depth 20.
with gate fidelity about 0.99
okay so uh
so that was roughly a thousand gates
each of which failed with probability
one in a hundred which meant uh these
were very noisy outputs that
and then uh
last year there was a there you know at
the university of science and technology
in china there were there was an
announcement about bozon something
experiment
which um which was um which was uh
effectively a larger hilbert space of
roughly 72 cubits there's 76 cubits
okay so um
so now uh
what you know so how do we get to
understand what quantum supremacy is so
let me just give you a little bit of a
backdrop to that and then okay so so
what's quantum supremacy well
for the to understand that let's just go
back to the the early history of quantum
computing so so the computer science
interest in quantum computing really
started with this notion that quantum
computers violate the extended church
during thesis
now
here's one way to look at it you know so
so why is why is quantum supremacy so
important well here's one way to look at
it so the classical description of an n
qubit state
is is this uh
is this exponential superposition right
so it's a
it's a it's a
it's a two to the n dimensional complex
vector
right uh where each amplitude
corresponds to the the amplitude of a
particular configuration a particular n
bit string
so
and
and of course when we when we measure
we don't get to see this superposition
we get to see almost no information at
all just just an embed stream
and so for all practical purposes
we could think that
um
you know that that uh that this quantum
state is a black box
that
you know that that nature protects
secrets extremely you know guards them
very closely
so that um
so that um you know you might think that
in fact nature is being so scrupulous
about it
that there's no way that we could we
could ever
experimentally
you know uh probe and and uh verify
that this that there's this
exponentially large hubble space
and so
in the you know in the early days of
quantum computing it was it was it
wasn't lost on us that
that once you have a violation of the of
of this extended gesturing thesis
you get implicitly
a way to
a way to probe hilbert space and and and
verify that the hilbert space was
exponentially large
right so
so for example you know
well if you did if you were able to do
this experiment
demonstrating an exponential speed up
then you would have a computational
verification that there was an
exponentially large hybrid space
and so
so
in fact you know quantum supremacy is
sort of sort of this this uh
um you know very jazzy new term
which which uh for an
experimental verification violation of
this
extended gesturing thesis
now
also already you know uh in the early
days of quantum computing it was it was
pretty clear
what you should do in order to in order
to do such an experiment right as soon
as uh
we had shores algorithm
that was you know uh
as long as we didn't care about the the
actual experimental difficulty
uh involved you know because this was
the early days you may as well assume
whatever quantum computer you wanted to
then shows algorithm was the natural way
to to carry out this experiment because
simple simple idea right you you input a
number
uh you get the factors from the quantum
computer you multiply them to see if you
got back that number and then you say
okay well that's it you know i i now i
now know that um classically it would
take an exponential amount of effort to
do this and therefore i have a i have a
real uh
verification that
behind the scenes there must be
an exponentially large object like
connect like i have
now
this notion started changing uh around
10 years ago
because expert you know because there
was a prospect that that experiment
would get close enough
right so now it was you know they were
they were back up the envelope
calculations saying that if you wanted
to do this with factoring
then you would need
uh
you know uh
thousands and possibly millions of
qubits you know we are where we are we
are just going to be nowhere close to
that
and so the question was could you
actually do this
without appealing to
to quantum algorithms the way we were
thinking about it
and so there were there were two uh
two proposals that that
that spoke about how one could do this
in the near term using using the kinds
of quantum computers one could envision
which would be very noisy
and so these were these were based on
sampling tasks so
you know where instead of actually
solving a computational problem like
factoring you would just
you would just use the quantum computer
to sample from some distribution
and so there were two such proposals one
one due to iron city and archipelago
bozon sampling and the other due to
brevard jose and shepard this was called
iqp
okay okay so
uh
so
at the end of the day what do we what do
we want from this uh from from uh from
this this sort of uh an experiment
so we want to say
look um
we have
some some device that claims to be
quantum
we are going to collect some statistics
from it
and then we are going to
we are going to
uh perform some statistical analysis on
this on this collected data
and so
uh
so so we we have some statistical
classifier which
uh for which we say okay our collected
data lies on this side of the line
and then together together with that we
also have
have um
some theorem that says
any classical device must sit on the
other side of the line
any any classical device that's
efficient couldn't possibly have
generated data that that lies on this
side of this dividing line
okay
um
and so so so we have some statistical
measure that distinguishes between
a quantum device
and any classical device that's
efficient so that that's what what the
what the
goal of this of this enterprise is
so so there are two parts to this
enterprise one is one is this uh a
statistical measure
um once you get this data how do you how
do you evaluate it and the second is
some kind of a proof
right a complexity theoretic proof
saying that any low complexity classical
device must sit on
one side of this
okay so so now where how do these
sampling tasks go so
so
of course we we knew from the you know
early days of quantum computing that
that this is what quantum computers are
are good for and in fact
uh
you know
uh
um
the the the sample from probability
distributions and you know even the most
basic thing you do with them is for a
sampling so so you know that's what that
that's what comes
very naturally
right
and but there was there's also this
sense in which probability distribution
generated by quantum
circuits look very different from or
quantum computers look very different
from those generated by classical
computers
and and
you know this was uh a bit but uh
um
somehow
you know
this this uh this was um
clear in this uh in this proof that bqp
lies in gap b it's the difference uh you
know if you it's
you can solve it by solving a counting
problem
but the kind of counting problem you
solve is you take the difference of two
to uh two sharp p functions
and the way this comes about
is
let's say that you have a quantum
circuit c which which works on input say
zero to the n
and now your output is you know you run
this quantum circuit and you measure the
output and you see what you get okay
so now we want to we want to understand
what's the probability
that
we will actually measure x
okay so so how do we figure this out
well
what you can do is
what you what you do if this was a
probabilistic
sort of circuit
then you would say
well look at let's look at all possible
computational paths that lead from the
input
you know through all possible branchings
and that eventually output x and let me
add up the
the probabilities of all these parts
so the probability of a part is the
product of the of the branching
probabilities along the path
and and now we just add them
now the the point with a quantum
computer
is that these branching probabilities
are actually complex numbers
but in fact the complex numbers don't
matter all that matters is that you're
allowed to have positive and negative
numbers
right and so
when you look at the
the
the probability to associate
with with a path it's actually a
probability amplitude and it's either
positive or negative
and so you'll have
you if you want to look at the
probability of x
what you'll have to do is look at all
those parts which give you a positive
positive amplitude
all those that give you a negative
amplitude and take the your your total
amplitude is the sum of these two so
it's the it's a plus minus a minus and
then another probability you actually
see x is the square of this
and so when you square this
what you will get is actually a plus
squared plus a minus squared minus 2
times a plus a minus right so so this is
where you get the difference of two
quantities
and you can you can
write each of these sums down you know
the positive quantity and the negative
quantity you can just
just sum them
separately and you get two sharp p
functions okay so so this is the this is
a
basic difference in a probabilistic
circuit computing the probabilities in
sharpie
quantum circuit computing the
probability that your output x is in gap
b
in fact it's gappy hard for the for
worst case uh circuit c
all right so so so far so good you know
at the time you know i said okay it's in
sharpie you know it's it's it's slightly
different from shakti you know it's in
gapi
okay but this was really a crucial point
and and and this was really something
that uh
that aarons and akapov and prep nation
uh chef had really uh noticed that
this difference is really quite
extremely important once you
once you start basing
you know trying to base
you know this quantum
supremacy on on sampling tasks and so so
why is that
well you know the
okay so so sorry okay so so already you
know already it was evident
that there's a there's a there's a major
difference which is
this thing
you know uh
if you want to if you want if you look
at the probability that that a classical
circum circuit will output x it's in
sharp
but you can also estimate it with an np
oracle
right so so
approximating this probability lies in
the polynomial hierarchy
once you're given the difference of two
sharpie functions
estimating that difference
is sharply hard
right so so even though these two look
very similar to each other this way in
terms of computing the value once you've
got to approximate them
this one is much simpler than that and
so quantum and classical are very
far apart once you once you talk about
approximating these probabilities
now there's a
but but
okay so but there's a there's a crucial
step from there which was which was a
really important i i think uh
um you know it's it's a simple step but
i think it's it's sort of a very
interesting you know it's a
it's simple but not entirely obvious
stuff
which was which was this
so so what they what ants and alcohol
and rap nature
observe which was really i think quite
quite important is that they said well
look
suppose that that you have a classical
computer that can
sample from the output distribution of
this of this quantum circuit
or even from a close pi distribution
so now you can use stockmar to say well
if you can sample from the distribution
then you can also approximate
this uh output probability
right
in within the you know with an empty
oracle so within the within the
polynomial hierarchy
and now
once you've actually approximated this
this output probability you've actually
separated these two
so
so so so
well okay so on shouldn't be done you
know should we now have a rigorous proof
that uh
uh you know that if you if you solve
this uh this sampling problem
then you couldn't possibly have done it
classically
right unless there unless uh
you know uh
unless the
uh
sharp you know the polynomial hierarchy
collapses you have sharp tv being
approximated inside there
collapse down to the programming
hierarchy
so the
answer lies in this this this fact that
this is for a rescue service
so
so this is for the worst possible input
and who knows what that is so what we
really want to do now is we want to say
actually it's
you know it's uh
it's hard to compute this this output
probability or even to approximate it
for a random circuit c
so that's that's the approximate
that's how this this um
[Music]
okay so
uh
so what was the what was the experiment
that google did that it actually did
exactly this experiment they
they had a
those are the couplers which which uh
through which you you can program the
gates
and
and so
so what they did was they fixed a
particular sequence of uh you know of
set settings
um
for for for 20 uh
you know for depth 20.
and so that was it that was a random
circuit c that was fixed they
initialized all the qubits to
zero
and then they they run this circuit
measured the qubits to get a 52-bit uh
random string x
okay it's a sample from the
you know assuming that this was really a
quantum computer then it was it was the
output of that quantum computer except
it was noisy
and very noisy right because there were
1000 gates each with 100 chance of error
now and then they repeat right so uh for
that same random circuit initialize
again you know take another sample and
keep doing this
and then
okay so now
um
in order to do this statistical test
they also needed some help so they said
okay now let's use a supercomputer to
compute
what's the probability that x should
have been output
if this this device that they had
was really this quantum circuit c that
they had picked
so that requires an exponential amount
of time but
luckily 52 is not that big and they
could use some heuristics and so on
we'll work this out
and now they needed to check whether the
sampled axis were consistent
but that was the whole experiment
okay so
okay so
so there were two challenges you know
one
how do you design this statistical test
and two
how do we know that approximating
this output probability for a random
quantum circuit is indeed
right and actually if we do know that
it's hard then by stop my something you
know we'd know that something from any
distribution with constant
division distance from
from this probability distribution is
high
so so at least we know that and then we
we need to design our statistical test
to check the
okay so
so now let me
uh
let me just briefly talk about what we
know about with respect to this
second question you know how do we
know that it's it's hard for random
uh quantum circuits or to what extent do
we know that
and then a little bit about the
statistical tests
okay so how do we know that uh
approximating this output probability
for a random quantum circuit so
well we want to
first case to average case reduction
okay so so
the first thing they're going to do is
we're going to model
they're going to
have a simple simplifying assumption
we'll assume that that the random
quantum circuit actually implements a
power random unit you know perfectly
random unitary on any qubits
so this is something that um
you know that appears to be true once
once you get to depth and
circuits
you know first well uh in the google
experiment they aren't getting quite as
far but but they seem to have uh
um
you know they experimented with it it
seems it seems like it's a it's a decent
assumption
okay uh
and then
what what what we what we want to do is
we want to model model this worst-case
average case reduction
after linton's permanent reduction
right so how do we want to do that well
let me just
ask a question that yes i'm sorry for
interruption is david david good morning
there is a borderline trivial argument
to show that the random classical
circuit
is not um
is it is hard just by counting right so
what goes wrong in in in this case
because you're bounding the depth i'm
sorry if i missed that or or what goes
wrong in this case just the counting
argument that if you randomly
uh sample the circuit then this just the
number of distribution will produce is
too much for for to be computed
you see so so
uh
it may be too much to be computed but
but we are saying
look uh you are even given an np oracle
and then a cd right so so we are trying
to distinguish quantum from classical in
the in the
in the
in the classical case you know we are
going through a stock market and saying
well you know but once you have an np
oracle it's easy to compute these things
and in the quantum case we want to say
it's even hard with with uh npr you know
it's it's hard anywhere in that
hierarchy that's that's what we want to
really get to
i see
yeah yeah thank you thank you
okay so
so just just uh uh you know just to make
sure we're on the same page let me just
do a very quick uh
review of
you know the way i'm
thinking about lipton's uh argument just
to
get our notation
you know
to match up
so
in
in the permanent case well you have some
uh
you have some matrix a whose permanent
you're trying to compute
and so you define this this uh
this other you know uh a one parameter
family of matrices you pick a pick a
random matrix r
and you know you in this case uh you're
working over a finite field
um
and say like a of t d x plus t times r
and now a of t is random uh for any
nonzero t
and then there's this very you know and
then you observe that permanent of a of
t is a degree and polynomial in in in t
and so and and that
what you're really interested in is
permanent of the f zero which is
fundamental of x
and so
so if you if you were to
compute
the permanent of a of t for n different
value non-zero values of of t
then these would be
n random permanence
and in the process you would have
computed
okay so i'm going to describe to you
what it takes to
actually
carry out this this sort of thing
in the in the context of
quantum circuits
you you need that sound for two design
so uh you know
and then there are their results saying
even along the way you get you converge
towards it
because you'd want for her and the new
one
okay but
you know but this is the simplifying
assumption and then we just
okay so
so let's let's try to put put the pieces
together for for such a reduction and
see what all we need
well one thing
that would be
you know convenient to have as a
polynomial somewhere
right so
uh
you know and and so what
you know the the first thing you know
sort of this is this is sort of the easy
thing to say that value output
probability of the quantum circuit is uh
you know if you have formats of m gates
then you can write it as a
as a as a polynomial
in the parameters of the circuit right
uh uh you know so if you if you let the
gate speed see one through the end and
then
you can sort of again take a
take some over all parts you know
uh
but now the
the place there's a problem with is
is
if you're trying to
if you're trying to uh
um
you know
somehow um
you know uh reproduce that previous
argument lifting down and then
but we run into a problem straight away
because
we can't take you know give it a circuit
c we cannot we cannot sort of take c
plus d times r you know
if this is a unitary and this is a
unitary when you when you take a linear
combination of them you won't get a
unitary
okay so
um
so so how do we how do we sort of go
from a circuit to a higher random
circuit
so there's an easy way to do it what you
could do is choose
choose a bunch of high random gates so
um
and
you know basically replace each a5
that gate followed by a higher random
gate
so so that gives you you know if you if
you start with any circuit you know
you'll end up with a circuit with this
power angle so that's there that's
that's that's
right uh
okay but now
there's there's nowhere uh univariate
polynomial structure right so which
connects this uh
the circuit we started with this new
random circuit
so so we should do something something
different
okay so
so here's what
uh
here's what we can do
so the thing we can do so the
the interesting thing in in in a quantum
circuit
is that
if you can apply a gate
you can also apply the
half of that bit the square root of that
gate or or any fraction of that bit
and so so what we what we can do is
that we we won't quite apply this fire
and we'll just dial it back by a tiny
amount
so that's this theta here
so
[Music]
equal to one then then of course uh
we we just dialed it back totally and so
we got back to the original circuit
if theta is zero then
then we totally applied this high random
gate and so it's you know doing that
where we were in the previous slide
but now we will assume we take it as
small
and so now each gate is very close to
power random
and and now we have the single parameter
family again right because we use
we're going to apply
different random random gates
for for for each gate of the of of the
circuit but we'll dial it back by the
same amount theta
but it's theta is the corresponding
parameter to t in the in lipton
right so now we have a univariate
polynomial well
we take a small theta and and then then
we want to then we want to work with
that
okay so
so so now there's still a problem
uh
the problem is that
you know this dialing back
you know this is not a polynomial in
theta
and so that's that's of course something
that's quite crucial to the uh
average case reduction so
so the solution is to take a
truncation of the taylor series
and now you can get very close
and
and you do end up with a polynomial in
peter and
and so you can now now go through there
through
the
template that um
okay so
uh
um
now of course when when you when we do
this truncation it introduces a small
error
it turns out that
there's a different way of doing this
which is a little bit more complex but
it's uh you know this is uh what mobasak
uh
did he showed that in fact there's a
different way to do this where you use a
use a keli path interpolation
and
you know which which actually stays
unitary throughout so you don't even
need this this error
okay
so um
so
all right so so uh
now um
let me let me talk about the error that
uh you know how robust this uh you know
so so this gives us a reduction but but
we have to talk about how robust it is
um actually while talking about the
robustness i'll actually talk about the
recent improvement that was that was
done by uh two
[Music]
okay so
so
how do we understand that so we we you
know we should understand that in terms
of polynomial interpolation
and this is over the wheels so so what
are we doing well
um
well we have some small
interval
you know within which theta
is allowed to uh
and
we we want we we we chose theta to be
very small you know with a small
perturbation
and of course where we want to go out to
is is is theta equal to one that's
that's where the worst case circuit sits
so this is where we collect the data
and uh
okay so the range in which we collect
the data
is
so we let this
this interval be of of of size one over
m where m is the total number of gates
right because because these are going to
add up and that that's that's where we
want these to sit
what we'll collect is
about m squared samples
you know
of equally equally uh space thetas
and now
we're going to assume
[Music]
that at least
two thirds of these
samples that we picked
are delta close to
the actual value that we were supposed
to get
right so so we are assuming that this
this uh quantum computer is noisy
one-third of the time it might just give
us complete nonsense
but two-thirds of the time it gives us
something that's an approximation to
what the true value is if you were to
use the true quantum stack of c
and now
of course uh
you know with this noisy interpolation
that would be hard but remember we have
an empty oracle so we don't need to
sweat that and so we'll just
find the polynomial
and now we need to bound how far away
okay so
so
um
so on the
you know in our in the in the previous
paper what they had shown was that
that that
you would
which is which is how close these
samples were that would get amplified by
exponential and m times
beta was this which was one over m so
n squared
but uh but you know ideally you want you
want to choose
delta to be roughly two to the minus m
so we really have to improve this a lot
so that's that's what these people they
they actually improve this to
for the
n times uh due to the order m times log
of theta
but as you can see order m log m is
still not good enough right so one you
want it to be linear
right because because we want to say
well this distance you know how bad you
know so eventually we want to say
well the worst case circuit is you know
the output probability is hard to
approximate to within within how much
well we want delta to be
sort of uh
small there
right we want to say well within
constant factor it's hard to approximate
or something
so certainly we want delta to be you
know
you know two to the order minus order n
so certainly we can't afford these login
factors here but even worse we can't
afford
n here it should be n right m was the
number of gates in the circuit there was
n times d where d d is a death
we really want two to the minus n so
this is really uh
you know it's it's a crucial thing that
one one has to has to improve for these
results to be
um
actually the
the improvement to get down to m log m
is really quite nice you know the idea
is to substitute theta as
x to the k so you you sort of uh
uh focus your attention on this this
interval
and
what that does is it leaves leaves the
end points unchanged
but now beta goes to beta to the one
over k
and if
so it sort of focuses the uh
[Music]
now
the the situation is much nicer if it
goes on something
because there um i'll just go over this
very quickly uh but uh let me just give
you a give you a sense of it so you have
n bosons and squared modes
uh
the degree of the polynomial is 20 n
but the dimension of the hilbert space
that you're working in you know these
are n bosons in n squared mode so you
get this uh um
you know it's this uh
balls and bins uh
right these are identical particles so
it'll be
the
dimension of the hilbert space would be
n squared plus
it's as though
you know this n log n is the is the is
the
is the important parameter here
and so we
uh
you know we don't mind uh
uh delta being 1 over
you know 2 to the n log n
and of course m you know this m was now
now n that's the degree of the
polynomial so so everything seems fine
except for the constants up here
and so
so for goes on sampling this this result
is within within a constant of six or
eight of being being meaningful
so
so there it's not clear that there's any
fundamental barrier to just charging
ahead and improving yourself
it actually
gives you a meaningfully professed
result
um
well because because uh
you know uh you you expect the
probabilities to be
roughly uniform right and then
then you want to have
okay so
try to
say is
just spend another five ten minutes just
wrapping up at this second
[Music]
observed
theoretical
you know probabilities of generating x
so
so the measure that was eventually used
uh in the google experiment with linear
cross entropy
which is just the expected value of for
so
so in other words you you you you
uh
you actually measure x
you compute p sub c of x and now you now
you now you compute the sample average
that's your your you're coming up with
an approximation for
the expected value of p sub c of course
so initially they started with a
different different measure which was
linear which is cross entropy which
would have been expected value of
uh minus log of p sub c of x and that
that also is is actually quite
interesting i can see a little bit about
that but but
when they run their experiments this one
did better and it's it turns out it's
it's a it's also a
good uh
and the intuition is
well
you know this the output distribution is
not going to be uniform it's actually
exponentially distributed
and so
it's almost uniform but but there are
some
you know some strings are somewhat
higher probability than others
and uh
and now you would expect the higher
probabilities outputs to show up
more often
and therefore this expected value of p
sub c of x
should be
should be larger than one over two to
them right which is what it would be if
it was completely flat and in fact
if you work it out then for a random
quantum circuit this expected value is
exactly twice what it would be if it was
you know let's do over here
so
so
well when they when they run the
experiment
you know they
their estimate was one point zero zero
two or two to ten
which they said well this is larger than
one over two to them therefore
actually
they did a little more than that they
said well look uh
this this is pretty uh um
you know it seems it seems like you know
this is only a small signal how do we
know it says this is really a signal and
not noise
and so they repeated this this
experiment thousands of times
and try to
you know
there's there's some some justification
for this but where where did the
does do these justifications come from
well
yeah various things but let me show you
um
uh
one one particular way of of justifying
this again and
okay so
uh
so this notion that
typically you will see you know you're
more likely to see heavy outputs than
light outputs
so this was formalized by aaron and chen
in this in this
challenge you know paul which says
well you're given a random quantum
circuit c can you generate
several samples x 1 2 x k
so that at least two thirds of them have
a probability
larger than medium
so if you if you look at the parameters
of this exponential distribution that
you get
uh this is you know the your quantum
circuit will satisfy this
it seems like a real challenge to come
up with first right here
so was the priority playing this uh
uh what would they yeah so so it would
it would
uh
um
[Music]
okay so uh
you you could um
i think then
you know you can you can define sort of
a dual problem which i'll which i'll do
down here
and then if you want them to correspond
to each other you you you you work with
the creator of 15k
so let me let me just uh
maybe let's let's see what what it would
play out here right so so
um
once once you move on to linear cross
entropy you you actually have to
you know think about this slightly
differently so there's a corresponding
version of this heavy output generation
which
which
really deals with uh
um
you know it's more quantitative
and for now the challenge is uh
you're given
a random quantum circuit c
you want to you want to generate
a bunch of samples such that
the average of um
the average probability
of this
sample under the circuit c
is
is at least
one plus b times two to the n
two to the minus seven so it's it's it's
larger than the than the expected
probability by this small amount
and so this is exactly the kind of uh
kind of problem that you know this is
this is almost exactly a
translation
of the
actual experiment
right
except that
except that in the actual experiment
well
what was the deviation
uh from 1 over 2 to the n
was it was it some constant or one over
polynomial times 2 to the minus n
or was it actually more like one over
two to the n where m was the number of
gates
right and i you know that that's that's
the one thing that one has to worry
about but
within that that distinction n versus m
distinction which is
which is a source of many problems here
and something that we have to think
through
but but this is this is a direct
translation up to that
and then
you can you can come up with another
come up with a conjecture which is uh in
the
you know you could you could think of it
as some sort of exponential time
hypothesis for or a type of it for
quantum circuits you know
so it's sort of going out on the limb
and assuming a lot of the thing
but there's no polynomial time algorithm
that
on
on input
a random quantum circuit c
now you want to you want to understand
with what probability does this random
circuit output the all zero string
so it produces an estimate for p zero
which is the probability that this
circuit output zero to them
with the following minimal requirement
so we want to produce an estimate
which is just slightly better than the
trivial estimate so the trivial estimate
would be
would be you would say p sub c you know
that p 0 must be 2 to the minus m
okay so all you want is to beat that by
a little bit in the following sense you
want that the
you know that the that the expect
expected square deviation from
you know
should be
should be slightly smaller
than
if you had guessed 2 to the minus 7 so
you look at the expected square
deviation here and you just want to beat
it by some
some other exponentially smaller one
now you can
you can actually
show with various parameters that
that
this assumption actually implies that uh
that
you know that
that that you couldn't possibly have
carried out this task classically and
therefore
if a device manages to do this it must
have important
and basically the way you do that is
first you you say well in these quantum
circuits you could you could always have
either flipped or not clipped every
output bits
so whether you're looking to
for this probability for the string 0 to
the n or some other string it's all the
same
so you may as well replace
this
all zero string by a completely random
string because you see because this this
this uh you know okay so we want to
search your x chord implies this so you
say well if there's an algorithm for
this there's an algorithm for this
but i'll go to this maybe you know who
knows you know it may be producing
strings in it in a particular way so
that it never produces zero to them so
so the the way we will do this
estimation is uh is we want to say okay
so we'll first say our task is to figure
this out for a random string
and then
and then the algorithm would be where we
just we just run this this algorithm the
the
the presumed algorithm for x log and
then
and then just see if if if this random
string occurs in this in these outputs
we'll say
oh yeah it has higher probability
otherwise it's same as one over two to
that
right so
so you say well it must have probably
one over b thanks to the minus n
otherwise you say
and then you just apply
some sort of markov inequality to say
yes
uh okay so i should uh i should really
uh
wind up let's let me just uh
just say a little bit about about all
this so
um
so
so there's this one issue that i said is
really quite important it's the number
of qubits versus the
number of gates
for random circuit sampling you know as
we saw
uh
we really need to
uh
not just get rid of this log n factor
but also
do this m versus n thing
it actually shows up also in this in
[Music]
of this uh kind of arguments you know
this end versus m issues really
and
and it's a it's an interpretation thing
with the actual experiments
um
i should also say that um
um
you know i you know as i mentioned there
there's there's also uh also um
uh instead of linear cross entropy you
could be looking at cross entropy itself
and then
for that measure you know it's possible
to show that uh that
in fact
you know if you if you see the right
measure you know the right kind of uh
output on the on the on the cross
entropy measure then
then in fact um
um
uh
you know you're within the within within
total variation distance so much of the
constitution
so
so um
you know so that that ties
the the cross-entropy measure to
this
worst case to average case reduction
but under under a certain assumption and
the assumption is that
if you look at your
your quantum computer
um
then then the output entropy that it
puts out is at least as large as the
output entropy of that this important
circuit that you were trying to simulate
so you you had in mind you know you
thought you were programming in a
quantum circuit c
and on input all zero to n there's
there's some output uh
distribution which has some entropy now
we're saying well whatever this this uh
this uh
the the quantum computer in the lab is
you know
its output distribution has at least as
high entropy
of course that's a reasonable assumption
in the sense that it's a noisy quantum
computer but but uh you know it doesn't
follow so
okay so that that's something that um
that uh that that is a consequence of
pinscher's inequality
now i i should say that there's there's
a whole other way of doing these uh
these kinds of uh
experiments through
for you know using cryptographic schemes
but uh
you know but but for those to be
uh
to kick in you know the the
um
the specifications of these these
quantum computers people are building
will have to improve somewhat both in
terms of number of qubits and the and
the fidelity of the qubit so
um
depending upon how optimistic you are
you could say well you know maybe we'll
get there in the next
next couple of years or not but
but but i would say that um
in terms of in terms of proving the
robustness of these these
these bounds which uh
you know which don't trip which which
are for these
um
these um experiments that don't rely on
on cryptography
i think that
not only is it relevant for the near
future
but um but it's also going to be
relevant uh
you know
later because because uh you know um
i i think that there are you know at the
end of the day there are they are there
are two or three motivations for
all this work one is you know it's a
it's a very important scientific
experiment in the sense that you're
looking into hilbert space and you're
saying well we're verifying something
about hilbert space which
which isn't a priori you know you don't
have thought it's possible to verify and
moreover
you know it's it's something that um
that we should feel obliged to do
because it's such a
you know
what what a
you know it's it's such a
um
you know
such an important condition you know
sort of it's it's it's claiming so much
about what's what nature is doing so we
should be verifying it another reason to
do it is um
you know it's a it's a step on the way
to
to building better quantum computers and
in particular
these techniques are are being used to
benchmark quantum computers and i don't
think that's going to go away
so
so
i think uh
you know even if we have these other
schemes for for
supremacy approved supportedness it's
not
you know the the earlier things are
still going to be of interest
thanks for agreeing to bring some
quantumness into our workshop uh uh
hopelessly now you have questions so
you know for sampling tasks we have
canonical classical types of algorithms
markov chain money parallel type
algorithms is there
uh okay and one thing that we have a lot
of people here who are interested in is
proving unconditional lower balance on
such algorithms for supposedly hard
problems um
is there some canonical
uh classical family of algorithms that
one would use if
there were
if this problem were easy that one could
study unconditional to prove
unconditional lower bones against
um
right so so um
for these you know there are there are a
few classes of algorithms one could look
into you know one is of course um
um just to find one part integral which
is just another
you know for us it's another name for
what would you call it they just uh just
look at all computational parts it's uh
i'm sorry
maybe
i'm sorry matrix multiplication um
yeah but for it for a general
computation right
okay
another another set of techniques would
involve
tensor networks right you try to you try
to break up the quantum circuit in some
ways
and um
i mean those techniques
you know
those techniques were actually used in
in um
you know so so there were brute force
computations up to a certain and for
computing piece of cfx and then
beyond that there were
you know
actually there's a
there
there's even a
paper now about spoofing the
the google experiment which uh
you know which which relied on a very
clever
observation about uh about uh
so in
uh
in your in your worst case to average
case reduction you've put a
a random unitary
in between each layer of the circuit
yeah
and i was a little confused because if
if we already believed that the circuit
of the entire circuit
is
in essence a random unitary
why didn't we just no no
we didn't uh oh why why do we why did
the uh
so the model seems to be that a circuit
is a
no no so so sorry um
okay maybe uh maybe i maybe i didn't
make this clear so
what we are starting with is
you know we
we are starting from the the the point
where i said look
if you wanted to compute uh the output
probability for for a quantum circuit in
the worst case
it's hard for gappy
right and even approximating it is hard
whatever right so so okay so we we start
from that that point
now that gives us a quantum circuit
right that's that's where the hardness
sits now we want to do a worst case to
average case reduction so we start with
that circuit
and now we insert random gates
in there so now we have randomized the
circuit
right and now this random distribution
we want to claim
is the hardest
right so that this this is sort of the
simplifying assumption
but we are going from a worst case
circuit
to
to a random circuit and then and then
we're saying well look uh in the
experiment we're just picking a random
circuit so what do we care it's this one
or that one's all the same so those h
sub eyes were like random two qubit
gates okay good that's that's what i did
related a bit to the answer to the same
question so something that
bothers me a bit here at the
so if we're convinced that there's no
that you cannot especially if we can do
if we can solve these problems in
polynomial time
uh you know uh then we're convinced we
have uh quantum supremacy but the thing
is that what we're doing is we're
solving them for a problem of size 52
and we're solving only or google is
solving them for problem size 52 and
also
only approximately right so there's lots
of other parameters here you can get you
know the
the edge that you get uh uh i'm sorry i
didn't get the last there's lots of
other parameters here rather than the
size like the edge that you get like you
don't because we don't the edge because
you don't get we don't solve it exactly
we only solve it approximately we get
some edge over random sampling right so
we only get it with a small edge and it
seems like two you know 52 is not such a
you know two to the 52 it doesn't it's
not such a large number but then when
you get since we only get an edge and it
seems like maybe i can do it in two to
the 30 which is something i don't know i
can do on my watch or something
is there a way to quantify
like what we should be you know
based on maybe a stronger assumption
about how you know what
what kind of edge and for what size
problem would convince us that really
this is not something we can do with the
classic computation right so so i think
that was that was the point of these uh
you know this um
[Music]
you know what i refer to as
sort of the analog of the exponential
time hypothesis right so this thing
saying saying that well if you have a
quantum circuit
you
now you're trying to
uh trying to estimate the
the the probability with which it
outputs a certain string
and
and the and the
and this assumption that you know that
uh ants and gun make uh you know which
it's a hypothesis that they're making
right there but but they're they're
saying there's no algorithm that'll
that'll give you
an edge of one over three to the n
okay so that edge is not a different
it's not a pulley edge it's an actual
yeah it's an actual thing saying you you
you know you you would imagine that we
wouldn't compute this probability but no
you know and it's close to one over two
to the n but right but you can't even
get but we're not getting that edge yeah
and and uh
and
but but um
you know but the thing that uh
the i and and so
um
you know that seems like uh
you know so so far we don't know of an
algorithm that achieves that even that
that small small amount it's uh you know
it's a bold conjecture but it's and then
the question is is it bold enough
right should it be
one over three to the n or should it be
one over three to the m
or one one over something to the m you
know so so if you use feinman path
integrals you can you can get an
edge of something which which is
exponential in m
but now if you dial it back just a
little bit and say okay you know i know
you can do it using using these boot
this brute force technique you can get
the nature of this much
but try to get me even anything even
slightly larger as a function of m
right and
now one could you know one could go out
on the limb completely and say well
you can't even do that
and then
well if you if you make that assumption
then then yes you would you would say
okay
yes we should uh
maybe this was um
you know one would have to check but
maybe one say okay well maybe maybe just
this small signal was good enough
but then
then you have to go back and say how how
confident are we that we you know
there's no no technique to
get us stabbed right so
well these things seem to require two to
the end an exponential number of samples
sorry so so are
you saying in order to do this uh you
have to you have to choose exponentially
many samples
well i guess i was confused about the
x-class thing because
the probability of getting a particular
output on average is one over two pn
and so most of the time you could say
zero
no no no but you're in export you're not
you're not saying you're you're just
giving an estimate
so you can't
you you you want to say
so you want to give a number p
right so you're looking at the circuit
and
you're analyzing it and then your your
your challenge is to output a number
and for example
one number you could output is two to
the minus seven without even looking at
the circuit right and you'd do you'd get
you'd get you know you get whatever
score you do on this
and now your challenge here is to beat
that trivialist you know
answer
by just this much
i i guess where i was confused is that
one way to attempt to solve these
problems is if it turns out that there
is a classical box
which produces outputs with the same
probability distribution as the quantum
box
then one type of algorithm for these
problems is to just sample from that
many times
but that's
well not actually the regime we're
thinking about here right i mean no but
uh but but no that's that's a i think
it's okay to think that way but then
at that point what you would say is well
if there's such a classical box
then you arm yourself with the power of
np and then you then you arm yourself
with stockmeyer and you say okay well
now i can now now i can go to the races
with this so then we strengthen x-class
to say there's nothing in the polynomial
hierarchy that can do that
you know so so so eventually i i yeah
maybe maybe that's a that's that's the
way to go with it but but i think this
is this is just sort of saying look uh
it's just it's just taking aim at it
directly and saying look
know uh did you have a classical
algorithm or not well if you did it
looked like this and
you wouldn't do this estimate then you
couldn't have free it was
just a direct implication
that's that pretty much